عراقيون يصرخون مطالبين بحق طيبه العلي
يوتيوبر قتلها والدها بحجه الشرف
والمتحدثه باسم خارجيه روسيا تسخر من
ماكرون كلام وعبث ومو كلام بالغ عاقل
وجوله على ابرز لحظات ليله صوت الارض
لتكريم الراحل طلال مداح اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
العراقيه مواليد 99 اسمها ترند ومالي
الاخبار والمنصات من بعد خبر مقتلها على
يد ابوها في العراق فيما يعرف بجريمه شرف
مع تحفظنا طبعا الكامل على هذا المصطلح
التفاصيل المتداوله بتقول انه طيب العلي
تعرضت للتحرش من سنوات من اخوها وعلشان
كذا تركت العراق وسافرت الى تركيا وعاشت
هناك وتعرفت على شاب سوري اسمه محمد
الشامي ونشات قصه حب وقيل انهم مخطوبين
وبدات على يوتيوب تشارك الناس حياتها
وحبيبها بيشاركها اغلب فيديوهاتها
اعذروني على شكلي مثل ما قلت لكم بالفيديو
اللي راح ما لحقت اسوي اي شيء
قناتنا اني ومحمد
قلبي قلبي
هذا اكثر شيء
وخاصه انه
اسم حبيبي
[موسيقى]
هالمعلومات المتداوله بخصوص الجريمه كثيره
وبعضها حتى متناقض فقيل انه طيبه بعد فتره
في تركيا حنا تحب ترجع وعرضت على اهلها
انه ترجع بس اخوها يترك البيت لكن اهلها
رفضوا ومن فتره طيبه جات على العراق عشان
تحضر خليجي 25 وتعرضت للتهديد المستمر من
اهلها وهي في العراق وبعدها امها ورشت
فيها وبلغت ابوها ورجال العيله بمكان
وجودها عند صحبتها فراحوا اهلها ورجعوها
على منزلهم في الديوانيه غصبا عنها ولما
وصلوا لبيتهم صار في خلاف بينها وبين
والدها اللي قتلها خنقا روايه ثانيه قالت
انها هربت من ضرب ابوها وحاولت الانتحار
بقطع الشرايينها لكن ابوها وصل لها وخنقها
قبل وروايه ثالثه قالت خنقها وهي نائمه
مين اللي منتشر كمان الساعات الماضيه
تسجيلات الصوتيه صوتيه قيل انها لصيبه
وانها ارسلتها لاحد اصدقائها قبل ما
يقتلها ابوها وكانت بتقول له انه كذا
حيصير فيها هذا غير رسائل مكتوبه كمان في
منها بتطلب منه اذا صار لها شيء ينتبه على
امها ويرجعها البيت ويقول لمحمد اللي هو
حبيبها ما يجي على العراق ويدفنوها وخلاص
المفروض انت
شو مسوي بيا
[موسيقى]
طلعني طلعني
انت عندك سهله
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
رجعتوني ليش
ابوي بنفسه اللي قال ابوي بنفسه اللي قال
اني ادري كرار مسويها ومتحرش بيك وانت
بنفسك
طيبه مشتاق لك لا ما تخابرني لو على مشروع
لو على مود رجعه لو على مود شغله قولي هذا
اليوم يا طيبه انا رجعت من الشغل نفكر بيك
وخابرتي وقلت لك بابا انا مشتاق لك قبل
انام
قلت لي طيوبه يا يوم قلت لي ام علاوي كنت
تقول لي قبل قبل لا يكبر ابنك
هذه التسجيلات والحكايات المتداوله عن
الضحيه عملت الكثير من الجدل وانتشرها
هاشتاج حق طيبه العلي مثل النار في الهشيم
وعراقيين بداوا حتى يتداولوا الصور لابوها
واخوها ويصفوهم بالمجرمين وحتى المنظمات
الحقوقيه في العراق كان لها رده فعل على
اللي صار فمنظمه ايسل لحقوق الانسان
والتنميه المستدامه نشرت بوست على صفحتها
قالت في القصه كامله وطالبت باعاده حق
طيبه العلي ووصفت المجتمع بالابوي الذكوري
اللي بينهش فيه النساء وبيفتك فيهم كل
لحظه واما المرصد العراقي لحقوق الانسان
فانتقد عدم وجود مساعي من السلطات لتشريع
قانون مناهضه العنف الاسري اللي لسه بيشكل
خطر على المجتمع بحسب البيان والكل طالب
السلطات التدخل في القضيه وايقاع اشد
العقوبات لكن كثار كمان استغلوا الفرصه
ليعلقوا على مسمى الجريمه اللي هو الشرف
اللي للمره الثانيه بكرر اننا في تفاعلكم
بنتحفظ عليه وانتقدوا القوانين الحاليه
اللي ممكن تخلي مرتكب جريمه مثل هذه زي
والد طيبه ينحكم بالسجن ثلاث سنوات كحد
اقصى اما السلطات فما في منهم اي بيان او
تعليق رسمي للان ولا حتى من الشرطه
المجتمعيه التابعه للداخليه واللي قيل
انها بتعرف عن التهديدات اللي بتتعرض لها
طيبه من عائلتها من ايام طيب معنى من
بغداد مصطفى سعدون مدير المرصد العراقي
لحقوق الانسان اهلا فيك معنا استاذ مصطفى
حضرتك اطلعت على تفاصيل هذه القضيه هل
عرفت اي روايه هي الحقيقيه
شكرا يعني لا توجد حتى الان الروايه هي
الروايه التي نستطيع ان نقول بانها روايه
حقيقيه وموثوقه مئه بالمئه لا احد يعرف
ماذا حدث في منزل
الضحيه طيبه العلي لكن هناك معلومات حصلنا
عليها من
مؤسسه امنيه
كانت هي المسؤوله عن
تحقيق وهي التي تابعت في محافظه الديوانيه
اجراءات هذه الجريمه
طيبه هي فتاه عمرها 24 سنه هي لديها نشاط
على السوشل ميديا
كانت تعيش في خلال الاشهر الماضيه في
تركيا بسبب خلافات عائليه عادت قبل اسابيع
الى العراق تحديدا عاده الى بغداد سكنت
وفقا لما مكونه في المحضر الرسمي عادت الى
بغداد وحصلت على تطمينات يبدو ان لديها
خلافات مع عائلتها حصلت على تطمينات
بالعوده الى محافظه الديوانيه لكن عندما
عادت يعني تعرضت للتعنيف من قبل والدها
اللي قتلها خنقا وفقا لمحضر
دون لدى السلطات العراقيه المعلومات ايضا
تشير الى ان والدها سلم نفسه الى القوات
الامنيه
العراقيه في محافظه الديوانيه هناك ما
ينسب لهذه الضحيه بانها تعرضت الى اعتداء
من قبل
اسرتها ونحن تحدثنا في المرصد العراقي
لحقوق الانسان قبل اشهر عن وجود حالات
تحرش في كل مكان وايضا في المنازل هذه
الفتاه هي ضحيه
لضحيه لما يعرف
داخل العوائل اللي هو مصطلح العيب يجب ان
لا تتحدث عن الانتهاك الذي تعرضت لا
تتحدثين عن التحرش الذي تعرضت له على
العكس لو انها تحدثت ولو انها لقيت اذان
صاغيه من قبل اهلها من قبل السلطات لان
هناك معلومات من يعني من المقربين منها من
اشخاص يعرفونها قالوا بانها ابلغت السلطات
اكثر من مره عن تعرضها للتحرش وايضا
يعني تعرضها للتعنيف داخل عائلتها وبانها
هددت بالقتل لكن لا احد يحرك ساكن نعم
هناك مشكله
في العراق وهي مشكله
الشرطه المجتمعيه الشرطه المجتمعيه لا
تتدخل مع كل الاحترام لجهودهم لجهودهم في
بعض الحالات تخشى التدخل في بعض الحالات
الحالات الخطره مثل حاله طيبه يعني
المجتمعيه تابعين للداخليه العراقيه اوكي
نعم نعم فالشرطه المجتمعيه هي واجبها
ولديها خط ساخن تتحرك على بعض الحالات لكن
بعض الحالات هي تؤكد انه لا يوجد هناك
انفاذ حقيقي للقانون في العراق تخشى يخشى
عناصر هذه الهيئه الامنيه ان
يتدخلوا فيها لاسباب ربما العائله تغضب
منهم ربما
يتعرض عناصر الشرطه الى ما يعرف
القوامه العشائريه او بالفصل العشائري او
يعتبرون بانهم تدخلوا في شؤون عوائل وفي
شرف والى الى اخره فبالتالي هي المشكله
مركبه هذه الفتاه هي ضحيه اعراف وتقاليد
سيئه وانا لا اقول كل الاعراف والتقاليد
سيئه وضحيه عدم وجود قانون لمناهضه العنف
الاسري منذ سنوات تنادي يجب ان نشرع قانون
يناهض العنف الاسري تاتي بعض الاحزاب
المتطرفه وتقول هذا القانون اذا شرع فانه
سيفكك الاسره العراقيه ابدا
سينظم سيدافع عن الضحايا سينظم حياه
الاسره العراقيه اكثر
هي ضحيه مشكله مركبه مشكله مجتمعيه امنيه
تشريعيه في النهايه يعني طيبه واحده من
يعني كثيرات زيها في يعني حوالين العالم
حتى يعني ما هي بس مساله عربيه او عراقيه
بحته فقط على العموم نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من بغداد مصطفى سعدون
مدير المرصد العراقي لحقوق الانسان شكرا
لك
في ختام الفقره المؤلمه هذه حقيقه ما في
كلام قال اكثر تعبيرا من المقطع اللي راح
تشوفوه الان ومتداول على المنصات لقت
متابعين تصريح لطيبه الله يرحمها بتقول
فيها راح يقتلوني راح اموت وركبوا عليها
هذه الاغنيه
[ضحك]
اكرهونا الحب
يكرهون الحياه يكرهون الورد يكرهون النساء
يكرهون النور
يكرهون السلام يكرهون الحب يكرهون الحياه
يكرهون الورد
[موسيقى]
احوال لبنان المعيشيه والاقتصاديه ما
بتخفى على احد وخاصه اوضاع الكهرباء اللي
شبه مو موجوده وفي مقطع صوروا مواطن
لبناني من داخل احد مكاتب شركه الكهرباء
في الجميزه عكس جزء من الحال الماساوي مع
انه هذه المره ما كان له علاقه بالكهرباء
نفسها وبصراحه ما في كلام ينقال تعليقه هو
يعني كفى ووفى حقيقه هذا هو المضحك المبكي
شباب هذه شركه الكهرباء بالجميزه هلا تحت
تحت الشتاء يعني لايف بدنا نبارك اول شيء
للمؤسسه
بافتتاح اول منتجع سياحي
باداره رسميه
افتتحنا البسين اليوم هون المكاتب
بدكم كهربائي هيدا هيدا البسين هون
بتكون كهرباء بلبنان
ايه يلا
من جديد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه قربت
تكمل سنه ويوم عن يوم بنسمع تصريحات ودعم
من الدول الغربيه الاوكرانيه بخصوص
الاسلحه ومن بدايه الحرب والاخذ شغال هذول
يصرحوا
التصحيح اللي بنتكلم عنه اليوم هو للرئيس
الفرنسي من بعد ما قال خلال مؤتمر صحفي
انه ما عنده مشكله في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالطائرات وانما بشروط وعدد الشروط خلينا
نسمعها
اوكرانيا
اكيد روسيا ومين احسن شخص يرد عندهم
المتحدثه الخارجيه ماريا زخرفه اللي
بتعتبر استاذه في علوم الردود غير
الدبلوماسيه زخرفه قالت لي ماكرون ايش هذا
الكلام السخيف ويعني لو الطيارات
يعني للناس من الطيارات وكملت عاد في
البهدله
[موسيقى]
اقيمت امس ليله صوت الارض تكريما للراحل
طلال مداح بعد 23 سنه على رحيله في حفل هو
اضخم حفل فني جماهيري تقيم هيئه الترفيه
وبمشاركه اكثر من اربعين فنان من 13 دوله
عربيه هذا غير عشرات الفنانين والشعراء
اللي حضروا الحفل وهذا الحفل اقيم على
مسرح محمد عبده في بوليفارد الرياض وكان
الحدث الابرز على المنصات سعوديا وعربيا
يعني بنتكلم عن ترند متصدر طبعا على تويتر
عشرات ملايين المشاهدات لفيديوهاتنا الحفل
على تيك توك بقيه المنصات يعني الى جانب
قيمه الفنان الكبير الراحل طبعا
الاحتفاليه الفنيه وتواجد كل هذا الكم من
النجوم من مختلف الدول العربيه كان حدث
بحد ذاته اكثر منهم غنوا على المسرح اخرين
قدموا اغاني فرديه من روائع الراحل وحتى
بعد انتهاء الحفل في صوره معينه انتشرت
اكثر من غيرها وفيها كبار نجوم الوطن
العربي مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ الحفل
الحضره كمان عائله الراحل طلال مداح واللي
قربتهم هيئه الترفيه كما اعلنت عن اطلاق
اسم صوت الارض على استوديو اس اس ال واللي
هو احد استوديوهات مرواس
ويتسلم نيابه عن العائله ابنه عبد الله
[موسيقى]
ما اجمل هذه اللحظه لحظه الوفاء اهل طلال
مداح رحمه الله عليه يصعدون الى المسرح
ليشاركوا الجميع هذا التكريم
[موسيقى]
تحيه لعائله الفنان طلال مداح
الحفل النقل المباشره عبر اكثر من اربعين
محطه تلفزيونيه الى جانب عرضه على قناه
هيئه الترفيه على يوتيوب ومن مفاجات الحفل
كانت اطلاله الراحل طلال مداح على المسرح
بتقنيه الهولوجرام
[موسيقى]
الوصف اللسان الحب مالي فيه
مظل لغيرك
[تصفيق]
متابعي الحفل كمان لقطوا كمان تاثر عائله
الراحل بغناء الفنان الاردني عمر العبد
اللات لاغنيه قولوا للغالي
[موسيقى]
قولوا له وشهوله
ما جاء ولا
هو الحب الله يكفي شره
وشهوله يبقي وشهوله
ولا جبر سوله الحب الله ينبشر انا علي
لو انشد واسوق المش
انه
الى
انشد واسوق المشايه همي زاد وفكري حاير
فارقني والفرقه مره
[موسيقى]
كواليس الحفل كانت مليانه باللقطات اللي
لفتت انتباه الجمهور ويمكن ابرزها مقطع
جمع رئيس هيئه الترفيه مع محمد عبده وعبد
المجيد عبد الله
الان نبي نقرا الفنان العربي ان شاء الله
ان الله يهديه ويلحن لعبد المجيد
نتذكر مره واحده حصل بيني وبينه
المؤلف
بس كلامي تعيس أنا
يلا خلاص اتفقنا اتفقنا
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه
تفاعلكم لليوم اترككم مع مقتطفات من اجمل
ما غنى نجوم العالم العربي في ليله سوق
الارض واعود والقاكم الاحد ان شاء الله في
امان الله
لينا التمر
[موسيقى]
عطريق يسافر فضح ارض البساتين
جرحت الظلام بالخل
وبلون الجميل
[موسيقى]
وحشني وانت في جنبي واشتاق لك لو
محسد عليك حتى نفسي مخ شايل
السكين توحشني وانت
بجنبي واشتاق لك لو تغيب
[موسيقى]
وراك الا التعب سيدي
مثل عينك تنام
لتعد مثل عينك
تنام
امانه حبيبك
بس اغني
على حسن حظ عشاني حبيبك
انا اشهد ان الله
احبه
واعطيك
اللي هداك الرب تصبح
واضرب واغني
[موسيقى]
وبادرك الغرام بكل فني
وش
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهد امتحني وانا وانت في ستر الليل
اعهدك بتعاني عشقت الليله ونجومه تشهد
والقمر
وانا وانت في سترلين عهد وانت بتعب
رساله حب تعبر عن عذاب القلب قصيده شعر
تحكيلك الم روحي
تناديني
يزيدك تحكي لك انا روحي
تنادي ما دمع يرجع
[موسيقى]
ولا احلفلك عجزت بلساني اوصف لك نعيم الحب
فيه وانت كريم
[موسيقى]